the Senate Judiciary Committee uncovers
a very weird letter from the Obama
administration to the Obama
administration plus is what Conda real
will discuss all of the glories of
wakanda the greatest place in the
universe I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
okay so we do have a lot to get to today
I'm gonna talk about the Senate
Judiciary Committee letter about another
email from Obama National Security
Advisor Susan Rice I'm gonna go through
that in detail the Robin Porter fallout
continues the media continues to worship
at the altar of North Korea and go crazy
over tweets from a New York Times writer
but I'm going and I definitely will talk
about that kind of stuff because
everybody is going nuts over Wakanda a
place that does not exist has not
existed and will never exist but
apparently is the great aspiration for
black people across the planet or some
such we'll discuss all of those things
but first I want to say thank you to our
sponsor is over at ring.com
so you've heard me talk about rings
innovative home security cameras camera
devices for a while they've been sending
us actual footage of ring busting crooks
in the act and here's one that I wanted
to share with you this is all just in
good fun this is a fellow trying to
break into a house and then you can see
how it all goes wrong because ring comm
is there to thwart his attempts Hey
leave my house I'm calling the police
okay what you need to do exams my house
stops now or I'm calling the police why
would you tell me that because you're
trying to push my door in leave now I'm
calling police okay he was not in fact
the police the police came
that's what ring.com does for you if
you're not home a I'm not sure even if
the homeowner was home here you can know
right away as soon as somebody brings on
the doorbell or knocks at the door you
get as soon as someone hits that ring
button you know on your app whether
someone is at your front door or not you
can talk directly to them you can call
the police you can use the ring spot
like him if you have that to do this at
night and obviously look this guy was a
nut job but very often when people are
breaking to your house they bring the
doorbell first to make sure that you're
not home and then they break into your
house well that's what ringing stops
when you can see what's going on at your
front door you can really stop crime and
it's pretty empowering with the ring
floodlight and spotlight cans you can
build a ring of security around your
entire property ring lets you protect
your home no matter where you are so I'm
3,000 miles away I still know when
somebody is driving up to my house you
can share your clips to help keep your
neighbors on the lookout for suspicious
activity thieves can
hide with ring stop crime before it
happens make your neighborhood safer
with ring save up to 150 bucks on a ring
of security kit at ring comm / Ben
that's ring comm / Ben again $150 off
that ring of security can't when I go to
ring comm / Ben who knows it could be
you featured in this video hopefully no
one tries to break into your house but
if they do you're gonna be happy that
you had ring comm and they use / Ben to
get your one hundred and fifty dollar
discount as well as letting them know
that we sent you alrighty so we begin
today with a little covered story that
is actually I think could be a big story
we don't know enough yet - no but we
will we'll find out I think pretty soon
Sun Monday the Senate Judiciary
Committee Senators Charles Grassley and
Lindsey Graham sent a letter to former
Obama national security adviser Susan
Rice and they asked her to explain an
email that she actually sent to herself
on the last day of the Obama
administration so January 20th they're
all getting ready to go the inauguration
and Susan Rice is at her keyboard typing
out an email to Susan Rice what exactly
is in this email well it explained that
President Obama had held a briefing on
January 5th regarding a supposed trump
brush of collusion so according to the
letter from Grassley and Graham - rice
says if the time stamp is correct you
sent this email to yourself at 12:15
p.m.
presumably a very short time before he
departed the White House for the last
time in this email to yourself you
purport to documents a meeting that had
taken place more than two weeks before
On January 5th 2017 it's like the last
minute she's in the White House she's
sending herself an email about a meeting
that was held in the White House
between James Comey the the then FBI
director the Deputy Attorney General
Sally Yates both of these people have
been fired or gone from the Trump
administration Vice President Biden was
present and Susan Rice was president and
President Obama was present so what
actually happened at this meeting
according to the email that Susan Rice
sent to Susan Rice says this quote on
January 5th
following a briefing by I see leadership
intelligence community leadership on
Russian hacking during the 2016
presidential election President Obama
had a brief follow-on conversation with
FBI director Jim Comey and Deputy
Attorney General Sally Yates in the Oval
Office
Vice President Biden and I were also
present President Obama began the
conversation by stressing his continued
commitment to ensuring that every aspect
of this issue is handled by the
intelligence and law enforcement
communities quote unquote by the book
the president stressed he is not asking
about initiating or instructing anything
from a law enforcement perspective he
reiterated there are lawn
foresman team needs to proceed as it
normally would by the book that's twice
she says by the book from a national
security perspective however President
Obama said he wants to be sure that as
we engage with the incoming team we are
mindful to ascertain if there is any
reason that we cannot share information
fully as it relates to Russia the
president asked Comey to inform him if
anything changes in the next few weeks
that should affect how we share
classified information with the incoming
team and Comey said that he would so
they're a bunch of things about this
email that Rice sent to Rice that should
be disturbing first of all why was she
sending a memo to herself the only
reason that you send a memo to yourself
legally speaking as a lawyer the only
reason you do that is to create a paper
trail so she wanted a paper trail
suggesting that this meeting was totally
hunky-dory which is why it says twice in
the email that this was all happening
quote/unquote by the book that in and of
itself is suspicious second how exactly
would Obama have planned to prevent the
intelligence community from handing over
information to the incoming commander in
chief I mean that's disturbing stuff we
talked about violation of presidential
norms well one of the presidential norms
is not just norms what is the law is
that when the chief executive comes in
when the commander-in-chief enters he
now has access to all the classified
materials but here is Obama saying to
Comey tell me what I should not tell the
President of the United States the
president-elect of the United States
tell me what I should not tell him the
implication being that the outgoing
administration was going to hide
information about the incoming
administration from the incoming
administration with regard to
quote-unquote Trump Russia collusion reg
Trump has full constitutional power over
the executive branch including the IC
but Obama said you might want to prevent
the full sharing of information
regarding Russia I mean talking about
violation of North shift the names here
and then imagine the fallout
imagine that George W Bush in the last
days of his administration had had into
his office the heads of his intelligence
community and Vice President Cheney and
he said to them listen I'm very
suspicious of this Obama guy it seems
like he has a lot of conflicting
feelings about the United States what if
we just don't give him all the
information what if we just keep that
hidden people would say well that's
insane I mean he's the president-elect
of the United States you can't do that
the President of the United States has
owed this information and yet that's
apparently exactly what Obama was
talking about third Obama said he didn't
want to interfere with anything from a
law enforcement perspective but how
about from an intelligence-gathering
perspective so Andy McCarthy over at
National Review has been aces on this
he says since the beginning there's been
a major distinction people have missed
between the Muller investigation as a
counterintelligence investigation and
the Muller investigation as a criminal
investigation these are not the same
thing a counterintelligence
investigation is an investigation where
you're attempting to determine if
someone's trying to influence our
elections if somebody in the United
States is maybe working with those
people but it is not a criminal
investigation in the sense that you need
to gather evidence for possible
prosecution well Obama seems to be
making the same distinction he's not
saying we're gonna prosecute anyone from
the Trump administration he is saying
that we're in the middle of a
counterintelligence investigation and
maybe that means that we shouldn't hand
over information to Trump so Grassley
and Graham asked a series of questions
that do deserve answers from Susan Rice
she's not famous for giving forthright
answers to certain questions
some of these questions why did Rice
send the email in the first place when
was she aware of the Trump Russia
collusion investigation because if this
meeting was about the Trump Russia
collusion investigation they were using
that as an excuse not to hand over
information to Trump and team that's a
problem and was Susan Rice aware of the
FISA warrants on Carter page was the
Obama administration using a thin a
thinly obtained FISA warrant on kyra
page in order to target the Trump
administration for future for future
curbs on their intelligence gathering
did Co me or Yates mention any media
coverage of the Steele dossier was Susan
Rice aware of the Steele dossier were
there any more meetings of this sort you
know we don't know the answers to any of
these questions but we better get the
answers to some of these questions
because this is a violation of serious
norms we keep hearing over and over
again then the Trump administration has
breached on this is not normal we hear
that all the time and listen I'm the
first to say when I think something that
is not normal is going on I don't think
that it's normal to have this level of
turnover in the White House in the first
year I don't think that it's normal the
President of the United States to say
what he said after charlottesville not
for him to suggest that he doesn't want
Haitian immigrants I don't think that
it's normal for the presidents of the
United States making excuses for an
alleged child molester in Alabama or for
him to suggest that a guy on his own
staff who's there's evidence of
wife-beating that that guy says he's
innocent and therefore met right I don't
think that any of that is normal but if
we're gonna talk about breaches of
normality that actually go to the heart
of the system this is one of them for
all the talk about Trump being the
incipient tyrant the hit layering and
figure who is going to come in and
overthrow all constitutional boundaries
just destroy the constant
and piece by piece that's not what's
happened the normans that trump has
destroyed have been norms of behavior
that's bad right but stuff that I don't
like because a lot of those norms I
think are good but if you're talking
about who perverted institutions the
Obama administration perverted
institutions far more than the Trump
administration has I mean this is the
Obama administration had an attorney
general who now us to talk about running
for president who called himself the
President of the United States his
wingman the Obama administration
militarized the IRS for use against
conservative nonprofits the IRS had to
apologise for that just in recent months
the Obama administration used the HHS as
a center of corruption under Kathleen
Sebelius the Obama administration was
utilizing the FBI in order to let
Hillary Clinton off the hook right the
Obama administration corrupted
institution after institution so when we
talk about violation of norms that's
where we should start
you know everybody's focused on on the
shiny object of the silliness of some of
the stuff happening inside the Trump
administration when we talk about norms
that have been destroyed and violated
that's that's not begin with Trump Trump
is a response to violation of norms and
the American public's had fine you want
to violate some norms we will violate
all norms how about that and ironically
the norms that have been reinstated are
those constitutional checks and balances
the norms that have been broken are the
cultural taboos that in many cases
probably should have stood in the first
place and none of that is good now in
this in a few minutes I'm gonna talk
about some of the norms that have been
violated by the Trump administration and
one that has not been violated but the
media are looking for an excuse to say
that that has been violated but first I
want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at LegalZoom so small business is a
hot topic this year that means the
national business month and LegalZoom is
coming at just the right time look your
business is starting to boom the economy
is doing well and now you're in growth
mode well that means you better get
paper topic as a lawyer I'm just telling
you you need to make sure that
everything is covered you do not have
time or money to waste on bad contracts
you do not have time or money to waste
when it comes to making a will or a
living trust right you need to make sure
that you are covered and that's what
Legal Zoom is for the new tax law
includes the most significant changes
for business owners in the last 30 years
LegalZoom can help you understand what
that means for you they're not a law
firm they have a network of independent
tax professionals and attorneys to
answer your questions about taxes and
everything else LegalZoom understands
you need to tap right into the resources
to run a success
business which is why they are using
their 16 years of experience to provide
business owners with the tools to start
and run the business the right way it's
pretty amazing I mean I remember when
LegalZoom was just Wells in trust and
now they've got legal advice that's
available through their network of
professionals meaning keep listening
over the next few weeks and find out how
LegalZoom can help you during national
small business month and you're not
gonna want to miss out in the meantime
check out legalzoom.com today got
special savings when you enter been in
the referral box to check out there's a
referral box that pops up check been
right and sir been there and you get
some special savings Legal Zoom is where
life meets legal legalzoom.com I've been
using Legal Zoom for years long before
they were an advertiser they're a
fantastic service and they're only
getting better and more sophisticated as
time goes on legalzoom.com for all your
legal needs and check been in the
referral box at checkout for some
special savings as well okay so the
media while they they haven't been
focusing on the violation of
institutional norms by the Obama
administration they're focusing in on
supposed breaches of protocol by the
Trump administration well some of those
breaches are actual breaches like why
was Omarosa working in the Trump
administration so Omarosa Manigault was
on the apprentice fired three times and
then Trump hired her for the White House
and then fired her again and now she's
on Celebrity Big Brother where
apparently there are rumors that she was
slipping out of her robe I haven't
actually watched the show so and now I
have no desire to do so
but amarosa actually on the show last
night she ripped into Mike Pence could I
just say this as bad as I think Trump
you would be worried about pence
everybody that's wishing for their life
we would be begging for days of Trump
back if pence became president that's
all okay the violation of norms that
went on here is why in the hell was this
woman anywhere near power she was a
celebrity reality TV contestant and then
she was ousted and now she's back on
Celebrity reality TV I mean there's a
hell of a career arc to go from reality
TV to the White House and back to
reality TV just spectacular
but is that violation of presidential
norms severely damaging to the United
States in the same way as say a prior
administration refusing to hand over
intelligence data I don't think so and
the media have been attempting to spot
violations of norms in every nook and
cranny every everywhere there are
violations of norton's this is not
normal this is what they're constantly
saying so yesterday for example they
decided to jump on Jeff Sessions the
Attorney General Attorney General
Sessions I think has overall been doing
a fine job and attorney General Sessions
was giving a speech about the sheriff's
office and here's what he had to say
since our founding they independently
elected sheriff has been the people's
protector who keeps law enforcement
close to and accountable to people
through the elective process the office
of sheriff is a critical part of the
Anglo American heritage of law
enforcement okay so everyone everyone
jumped on that phrase the Anglo American
heritage of law enforcement oh he's
saying white people ooh
controversy he's saying white people
brian schatz the idiotic senator from
Hawaii IQ of seven he says do you know
anyone who's has Anglo American heritage
in a sentence what could possibly be the
purpose of saying that other than to pit
americans against each other for the
chief law enforcement officer to use a
dog whistle like that is appalling best
no vote I ever cast okay this is as
Charles Cook says over a national review
politely this is this is moronic okay
this is idiotic the Anglo American
heritage of law enforcement and the
Anglo American heritage of America's
legal system has been commented on by
virtually every president it springs all
the way back to you globally back to
William Blackstone which was used as the
basis for a lot of American law and
British common law was the basis for a
lot of American law here's senator here
senator Obama in 2006 before who's
president talk about habeas corpus quote
I sincerely hope we can protect what has
been called the great
a right that has been in place in the
anglo-american legal system for over 700
years clearly Barack Obama was a racist
in 2008 during the campaign quote
calling it the foundation of
anglo-american law he said that the
principle of habeas corpus says very
simply if the government grabs you you
have the right to at least ask why was I
grabbed right so again talking about the
anglo-american law and then there was
President Obama saying quote the Obama
would not say whether it could be
achieved within the first hundred days
of his term citing the challenge of
creating a balanced process that it
here's the rule of law habeas corpus
basic principles of anglo-american legal
system how dare Jeff Sessions how dare
Jeff Sessions this is what I'm saying
about why people don't trust the media
okay when you guys go looking for
reasons you say this is not normal about
Trump but then you completely ignore
this is not normal about Democrats then
we start to think that maybe just maybe
you have a little bit of bias speaking
of bias and normalization of terrible
behavior okay a top DNC official keith
Ellison dined with Louis Farrakhan and
the President of Iran in 2013 it is
according to Fox News Democratic
National Committee Deputy Chair Keith
Ellison who is an anti-semite raging
anti-semite attended a private dinner
hosted by Iranian president Hassan
rouhani in 2013 along with the head of
the black nationalist group Nation of
Islam Louis Farrakhan you'll remember
that this guy was endorsed by Chuck
Schumer to become head of the DNC you'll
also remember that he said at the time
that he had completely cut ties with
Louis Farrakhan yet there he was in 2013
having dinner with the president of a
genocide 'el anti Jewish state in Iran
and the head of the Nation of Islam the
anti-semite Louis Farrakhan Ellison also
visited with Farrakhan again in 2015
Ellison attended the 2013 general with
two other members of the CBC the
Congressional Black Caucus
representatives Andre Carson Democrat
from Indiana and Gregory Meeks Democrat
from New York
rouhani invited Muslim leaders from
around the United States to dinner after
addressing the UN General Assembly and
the Nation of Islam website confirmed
the attendance of Louis Farrakhan and
then there are articles at the Nation of
Islam publication confirming Ellison
there with photos of Ellison Ellison and
Farrakhan at the table right after the
guests were hosted at a dinner the
Iranian president answered and engaged
in warm discussion with guests including
Democratic congressman Greg Meeks of New
York keith Ellison of Minnesota who is a
Muslim and this is what final call wrote
or not
/ second 2013 this of course is not the
first time Allison has been associated
with Louis Farrakhan I Wilson attended
the Million Man March in 1995 and
publicly defended Farrakhan years ago
even after Farrakhan made a bunch of
anti-semitic remarks and called Jews
satanic hey Farrakhan slammed Ellison in
2015 after Ellison tried to distance
himself from Farrakhan but this is
what's truly amazing the media are
willing to go crazy over Jeff session
saying anglo-american which is totally
fine right totally fine Barak Obama said
it there's nothing wrong with saying
anglo-american law enforcement heritage
the the office of Sheriff is a is a is
an actual concha it's an actual smashing
together of two terms from British
common law Shire and Reeve right Shire
and Reeve Sheriff
can that's where it comes from of course
it's a feature of anglo-american law
that is something the media have to
comment on that's something we have to
be deeply concerned about is that it was
coded white people language when it
comes to actual Democrats dining with
actual terrorist leaders and actual
anti-semites nothing not a word we all
have to pretend that keith Ellison is
totally normal we have to pretend that
keith Ellison is just a normal part of
American politics this is not normal you
don't talk about this is not normal that
is not normal that is not normal now
speaking of not normal the media
continued to fawn over North Korea
because North Korean sister kim yo-jong
i can't remember her last name young yo
or her first name because in korean then
the names are opposite western in any
case now the the media continue to fawn
over over north korea remember they were
fawning over north korean cheerleaders
it is worth noting that is an update to
yesterday north korean cheerleaders have
been sent to prison camps before
according to vice news
says after a 2005 performance 21 members
of the cheerleading squad were sent to a
prison camp after speaking out about
what they saw in North Korea in South
Korea
critics say the army of beauties is an
effort to hijack the games and spread
propaganda which of course it is the
head of propaganda is the sister who
everybody was praising as just wonderful
and glorious
kim yo-jong is her name sorry that's the
name of the the sister again and then
the media continue to cover vice news
doing something most of the media did
not do there's some talk yesterday about
the fact that Fox News gave even some
flaunting coverage to the North Korean
charm offensive the Breitbart did as
well well we didn't hear it say Lee
Weyer Nord we tolerate it because that's
silly
okay so just because whether it's right
or left if you were if you were
crediting the North Koreans with a
wonderful PR push then number one you're
demonstrating complete ignorance of the
system in North Korea and South Korea
you know the truth is that the South
Korean government was going to portray
all of this as fine and dandy because
the South Korean government the recently
elected government is called the
sunshine government meaning that one of
their stated purposes is to push the
idea of a unified Korea with
conciliation with the North Korean
regime and it wouldn't matter what North
Korea did I mean the sister could have
come down and taken a dump on the
president's table in South Korea and
they were portrayed as some sort of
great diplomatic coup the people of
South Korea however are not happy with
the North Koreans and they're not happy
with the North Korean regime so all of
the talk about this charm offensive are
wildly overstated as speaking of media
stupidity I'm gonna come into the fence
of a woman named Barry Weiss Barry Weiss
writes for The New York Times and she
was shellac she's an opinion writer and
staff editor she was she lacks because
she did something terrible the NBC
Olympics who covered a woman named
Mariah I'm watching any of this I'm
gonna mispronounce all the names Mariah
ngoz ooh who's an American an American
ice skater an American figure skater who
was the first woman to land a first
American woman to land a triple axel in
competition and Barry Weiss tweeted out
immigrants they got the job done and now
she knows that mariah negocio is the
daughter of immigrants she's not
actually an intern she was born in the
United States but her parents emigrated
and she was just taken to the woodshed
over this right she's an American
citizen having been born to Japanese
immigrants living in California the the
the line there right there
where she says immigrants they get the
job done it's actually a reference to
the musical Hamilton and Barry Weiss
tweeted back her parents are immigrants
the whole thing was a compliment I
deeply resent the implication her tweet
right somebody tweeted back at her was
the poetic license in saying she looks
Asian so she must be the immigrants
despite being born in California no
that's not what she was saying at all
it's amazing the level of the level of
anger the level of disdain for anyone
suggesting that perhaps a child of
immigrants is successful in the United
States is just insane right
he's Shaun Thorson so she's not white so
she has to be an immigrant I mean and
Barry White Barry Weis tweeted back wow
this is utterly breathtaking in its bad
faith her parents are immigrants and my
tea was obviously meant to celebrate her
accomplishments well yes perhaps you'd
be more comfortable with an alo like
Think Progress making the same point
this is it's all true but people are so
oversensitive now people are so crazy
that they decide that Barry Weiss is the
person who has to pay the price for all
of this how dare Barry Weiss make a
point about the children of immigrants
doing really well in the United States
hey this is how far left everybody's
moved what utter utter insanity okay in
just a few minutes in just a few seconds
I'm going to talk about the continuing
fallout from the Rob Porter scandal and
what's going on inside the White House
we're gonna talk a little bit about and
then we will talk a little bit about
Black Panther first I want to say thank
you to our sponsors over at Dollar Shave
Club so Dollar Shave Club is gonna give
you everything you need to look feel and
smell your best I mean look at me I'm
just a magnificent specimen of humanity
I'm all that life has to offer okay and
if you don't believe me then you go over
to Dollar Shave Club and try it yourself
I am so great because Dollar Shave Club
is fantastic they give you a great shave
they will give you great products for
your face for your for for the rest of
your body for the body's hope they'll
give you even the fabled butt wipes they
have everything they have everything
shampoo body wash toothpaste and of
course the best razors that anyone has
ever used maybe I get that amazing
high-quality shave right under here from
my Dollar Shave Club executive razor
okay go for the gold join Dollar Shave
Club today for five bucks with Free
Shipping you'll get their starter set it
has the six blade executive razor plus
trial sizes of the shea butter body
cleanser and the one wipe Charlies
oh yes they are magnificent then keep
the blades coming for a few bucks more
month get yours at dollarshaveclub.com
slash man that is dollarshaveclub.com
slash pin again they have all the bath
products that you need no longer will
you have to worry about running out to
the store because you ran out of soap in
the middle of a shower now you've got
Tyler shave club sending you that stuff
every month when you subscribe go over
to Dollar Shave Club today and for five
bucks you get free shipping for their
starter set so go and get that right now
dollarshaveclub.com slash been again
that's dollarshaveclub.com slash been
and use that slash pen so that they know
that we sent you already so the fallout
continues over at the white house over
rob porter and you can see that the
media are all over this largely because
they think that this is a way to get
Trump they they think that if they can
get Trump to acknowledge that Rob Porter
is probably guilty then they can get
Trump to acknowledge that Trump is
probably guilty of sexual harassment and
sexual assault now what's the difference
between Rob Porter and Donald Trump the
difference is that everybody knew about
all the allegations against Trump when
he was elected I said this with regard
to Roy Moore because people were
comparing the two the difference here is
that the allegations against Trump had
been widely aired by the time of the
election okay that doesn't excuse the
vote if that if you think then he's an
excuse but it does suggest that people
took all of that into account when they
made their binary choice between Hillary
Clinton and Donald Trump the same is not
true for Rob Porter Rob Porter was
supposed to be this clean-cut guy that
everybody in the White House liked and
trusted and then it comes out that he
allegedly beat two of his ex-wives that
comes out now people are suggesting that
that's akin to Trump well whatever you
think of Trump the American public have
already judged whether they think Trump
is guilty or innocent on the basis of
the allegations that have already been
aired if they're new allegations maybe
that changes the math a little bit but
the media are attempting to use Rob
Porter to ensnare Trump Jim Acosta
trying to do that on CNN last night it
seems like the president was believing
mr. Porter as opposed to his alleged
victims why did the president tweet that
over the weekend why is he seemingly
defending mr. Porter publicly is it
because he has based his own allegations
is there some sensitivities or is that
like why that is
as I just said and I'll repeat it again
the president in the entire
administration take domestic violence
very seriously and believe all
allegations need to be investigated
thoroughly he certainly supports the
victims of domestic violence above all
else and believes that they should
everyone should be treated fairly and
with due process the president simply
saying that there should be a process
that that should be followed and looked
at is there just a being on the wrong
side of things being on process okay so
there's a cost of trying to grill sarah
huckabee Sanders and the entire media
was doing this yesterday doing the work
of the Democrats as well Terry McAuliffe
who obviously wants to run for president
the the governor of Virginia
he said that President Trump has no
sympathy for victims of abuse obviously
this president has more sympathy for
domestic abusers than the victims of
domestic abuse I mean it's just sad it's
a continuing litany we've heard from
this president and this is a very
serious issue
this is taxpayer-funded money being used
to cover up domestic abuse in brock
quarters domestic abuse absolutely
okay bringing on Terry McAuliffe to talk
about this is just absurd Terry
McAuliffe was one of the clinton's
biggest supporters and he was perfectly
fine with everything bill clinton was
doing to women and was alleged to have
done to women again democrats are using
this as a club against trump this is
really less about protecting victims of
domestic violence because we're not even
talking about rob porter anymore are we
we're not even talking about what
happens to rob porter we're now talking
about trump i rob port has been gone for
part of a week right he's been gone for
several days at this point but Rob
Porter has faded into the background now
we're gonna talk about Trump because
this is a way to get Trump bring on
Terry McAuliffe to talk about this is
obviously a partisan exercise by members
of the media kirsten gillibrand doing
the same thing she says we should force
Trump to resign and if not then Congress
should hold him accountable on all this
domestic violence of again not the
allegations that Trump himself was
involved in domestic violence but the
allegations that his own staff didn't
tell him the Rob Porter was alleged to
have been involved in domestic violence
yeah it's not clear that goes all the
way up the chain of Trump from what I
hear it absolutely does not anyway
here's Kirsten Gillibrand the senator
from New York a woman who spent most of
her career defending Hillary Clinton
Bill Clinton once President Trump was
elected I think
something changed and I think it changed
for women do you think he'll be held
accountable well and I mean I think he
should resign and if he's unwilling to
do that which is what I assume then
Congress should hold him accountable we
are obligated to have hearings I mean
this is the same woman who Meghan McCain
took part in two questions on the view
simply by saying the name Clinton and
Kirsten Gillibrand ran for the hills and
this is the point if Democrats are
hoping that they're gonna be able to win
Congress win the Senate win the
presidency simply by being anti Trump I
don't think that's going to work it's
all baked into the cake okay it's all
baked in already I've made this clear
with regard to Trump I think the Trump
is a mud monster meaning that if you
throw more mud at him it doesn't even
show up everybody knows what Trump is at
this point but Democrats are gonna
continue beating this drum Chuck Schumer
I think knows better right he's saying
you can't just run against Trump he's
not the only one by the way
but our mistake I think you cannot just
run against Donald Trump and it is the
job of we Democrats to put together a
strong cohesive economic group of
proposals aimed at the middle class and
those struggling to get okay but they're
lazy so they're not gonna do that
okay and they're even being encouraged
by their own people they need to do they
need to get away from bashing Trump
full-time according to McClatchy today a
leading Democratic group Priorities USA
which is a vile group right there
warning party leaders they could
squander a strong political climate in
2018 if they don't start to emphasize
pocketbook issues over loose and
unfocused critiques of Donald Trump
according to internal polling by the
super PAC president Trump's approval
rating climbed to 44 percent in the
first week of February compared to 53
percent who disapprove that mirrors
Trump's improving position in public
polls in November the same survey found
his approval rating at 40 percent with
54 percent disproving the group survey
also showed the Democratic Party's
generic ballot advantage had shrunk with
46 percent preferring Democrats to 42
percent for Republicans that's not going
to be enough for Democrats to win back
the house they need about a seven to ten
point ballot advantage in the generic
ballot if they even hope to win back the
house the memo says that a broad range
of metrics showed the political climate
is still favorable for Democrats but it
also makes an unambiguous diagnosis for
Trump's recent rise Democrats this year
have stopped focusing on economic and
health care issues topics that
demonstrable hurt his approval during
his first year in office priorities
polling found that while people in
November readily mentioned Trump's
health care and tax reform measures by
February they were instead more
of his tweets well one of the reasons
for that is cuz Democrats can't argue
healthcare Democrats can't argue the
economy the economy is doing well and
millions of people are not dying because
of the reforms to Obamacare so all of
the talk about that is gone by the
wayside and they've fallen back on their
secondary argument which is that
President Trump is a garbage person
right this is the why they're going
after the Rob Porter scandal with
alacrity what they should remember is
that every time they attempt to get
Trump with one of these sorts of
scandals it fails a bleep whole gate was
three weeks ago does anyone even
remember that is that even a thing that
happened or the stormy Daniels was like
two weeks ago right the allegation the
President of the United States had
nailed the pornstar and then paid her
off to shut up about it during the
election cycle that lasted for like five
minutes in the media they the idea that
Democrats are gonna win back the House
of Representatives simply by bashing
Trump about Rob Porter is in a now does
that excuse the behavior of the White
House on reporter of course not I spent
a lot of this week bashing and last week
bashing the White House over their
treatment of the Rob Porter situation
obviously no one who was alleged to have
done that stuff and was forbidden FBI
clearance because of it shouldn't
anywhere close to the Oval Office
but if Democrats are hoping that they're
just gonna be able to rail against Trump
and this is somehow gonna drive people
out of the polls not so much not so much
from the memo according to Priorities
USA they say there's no questions from
benefits when a critique of his tax and
health care policies is not front and
center especially when voters are
hearing Trump side of the story on the
economy so fascinating Democrats are
beginning to see that what they're doing
is a problem but they can't stop
themselves they're so addicted to Trump
hates that they're they're having a
really tough time breaking away from it
they're gonna have a tough time moving
away from from basing their entire their
entire campaign on how much they dislike
President Trump
okay so in just a minute I want it's cus
the most important thing happening today
we haven't discussed it yet the most
important thing happening today is of
course black panther is coming out in
two days and this has been true for
several days the most important thing
happening yesterday was that black
panther was coming out in three the most
important thing happening four days ago
was the black panther would be coming
out in seven days right all of this has
been deeply important for years the most
important things happening on the planet
right now are the happenings of a Marvel
movie in a fictional country very very
important I'm gonna talk about that in
just a second because it's so
importantly important but first I want
to say thank you to our sponsors over at
legacy box so the most important thing
can do this year I think Bar None is
preserve your memories hey never know
when there's gonna be a flood in your
garage and all of those films all those
pictures that are gone right you never
know when all of that history from your
family is out there in the garage and
it's just moldering and God forbid
there's a fire or maybe it just breaks
down right the film breaks down over
time this is why you need legacy box so
the way legacy box works is they send
you a box you take all of those old
films and you take all of those old
pictures and you put them in the box
they put labels there for you to put all
your to label all of your items with a
barcode so you can trace it through the
process then you send that box back to
legacy box and the good folks over at
legacy box take all that stuff and they
put it on a DVD or a thumb drive so now
all of your family amount of your family
memories are no longer stacked up in the
garage on waterlogged boxes that are
collapsing in on themselves instead
they're sitting in your library next
your DVD player and the thumb and drive
it's on your keychain you can always
have those memories available to you at
all times you no longer have to worry
about passing them and passing them down
generation to generation and ensuring
that future generations remember you and
and remember and that you remember your
own your own childhood that you remember
all the good memories that you have with
your kids legacy box is making sure that
these irreplaceable memories don't have
to be replaced make 2018 the year you
preserve your family's legacy
that's what legacy box is for for a
limited time you save 40% over legacy
box comm slash pen that's 40% at legacy
box.com slash men you can get start for
just $45 right now at legacy box comm
slash Ben legacy box comm slash Ben this
mix by the way a great Valentine's Day
gift okay tell your your loved one that
you took all of your memories and you
have them put it on DVD or thumb drive
so now they're all accessible all right
this is a great Mother's Day or Father's
Day gift great birthday gift for mom and
dad legacy box com / Ben legacy box calm
/ man use that / Ben's he get 40% off
and get started right now for 45 bucks
and use the slash pen as well so that we
so that they know that we sent you as
well okay so everyone in the media is
talking about the most important thing
that has ever happened in the history of
humanity or at least since Caitlyn
Jenner became a woman a transgender
woman and that of course is the release
of Black Panther it is so deeply
important it is we've heard is deeply
important to millions of black americans
who after all we're not liberated from
slay
every two hundred years ago and
liberated by the civil rights movement
with federal legislation and not been
gradually restored to what always should
have been full civil rights in the
United States and none of that has
mattered up till they made Marvel movie
about a superhero who is black in a
country filled with black people that is
the real that's the change right blade
was not enough
Catwoman with Halle Berry no ok well
Conda is where it is this is the most
important moment in black American
history not Martin Luther King not
Frederick Douglass not the Civil War not
the end of Jim Crow none of that
not Brown vs. Board the most important
thing is that chadwick boseman puts
claws on his hands and a mask on his
face and runs around jumping off cars in
CGI fashion deeply deeply important
black children everywhere will now
believe that they too can be superheroes
who jump off cars in fictional countries
it's very important now you may sense
that I'm mocking a little bit the reason
I'm mocking a little bit is because I
hate this kind of identity politics I
think it's incredibly stupid I think
it's incredibly stupid because again I
grew up as an Orthodox Jewish kid where
no American president has been Jewish
and no American presidents been Orthodox
Jew and yet I grew up on 1776
essentially worshiping the founding
fathers none of whom were Jewish and
yesterday my daughter actually is on on
Shabbat am i sitting around my daughter
and my daughter was talking about how
she said what the president's cuz she's
learning at the president about the
presidents in preschool
she's very politically active my
daughter she's four years old and she
knows many of the presidents she is
familiar with the life stories of
Abraham Lincoln in George Washington and
she said daddy was George Washington
Jewish and I said no he wasn't and she
said it's not on Trump Jewish I said no
he's not and she said have any of the
president's been Jewish and I said no
and she said why haven't any of the
president's been Jewish and she's four
so I didn't go into the full explanation
but what I said is you know they just
haven't been but maybe there'll be a
Jewish president the future would you
like to be President one day she said I
don't know it sounds boring and so which
i think is an astute observation on the
part of my daughter but the point is
this right if you're not telling your
kids they can be anything in America
you're doing something wrong as a parent
and if you had to wait until black
panther came out right we heard this
about Barack Obama one who's elected to
now that Obama has been president black
Americans will feel like they too can be
President
formative moment and yet all we hear now
is that America's deeply racist and
black people are still systematical is
systemically discriminated against and
the black people are still victims in
American society so it turned out didn't
mean anything but Obama was president we
were told to mend everything and then he
was president for two terms right
re-elected overwhelmingly and then it
turns out it didn't mean anything
because we needed a Chadwick Boseman to
somehow make sure that black people felt
accepted in American society because a
bunch of white executives at Marvel
greenlit a film about black people in a
fictional country in Africa then the
insanity that is attended Black Panthers
it's crazy I'll see the movie this
weekend I hope that it's good Simon to
spend money on it so anything I spend
money on I hope is good but you know I
will give you an honest review of that I
know that's been forbidden by the media
there's actually a law that you're not
allowed to give your opinion on black
panther emily locked awawa
i think summarizes the the feelings of a
bunch of insane leftist white social
justice warriors she tweeted this out
yesterday and it's totally crazy she
tweeted out quote so i carefully did not
buy a black panther tickets for opening
weekend because i did not want to be the
white person sucking black joy out of
the theater what's the appropriate date
for me to buy tickets is next weekend
okay I think the appropriate thing for
Emily Locke de Walla to do is never to
leave her home again or tweet I think
these would be because honestly you
never know when you're gonna offend
someone just by your very presence like
the necklace that she's wearing here I
think it's ugly and it's it's ruining my
white person joy today wait what kind of
insanity is what does she think of black
people like how how derogatory do you
have to think of black people to think
that if you're in a theater with a bunch
of black people they're gonna think that
white person sitting here in a theater
watching a movie talk about how black
people are awesome that's ruining my
black joy first of all what is black joy
and why is black joy different from
white joy or different from home and joy
for that matter I'm just I'm confused
what what what are we even talking about
here but the sensitivity police have
gone so far that we now have to have
fully segregated theaters to make sure
that black people are not offended by
the presence of white people according
to Emily Locke de Walla now we actually
have to segregate the theaters it's
amazing I mean we could do the converse
we could do the cut we did the converse
for a couple hundred years in this
country right the converse was black
people don't be allowed into white
people theaters because that will offend
the white people and ruin their white
joy this is stupid folks this is not
only stupid it's counterproductive to
the notion of a good and honest
and free American society and then the
New York Times has run a series of
pieces this week these long pink pieces
about Ryan Coogler film okay so they're
there too that I spotted right off the
bat one by Salim Isha Tillett I don't
know who selling Misha till it is I
guess someone Misha Tillett is well I
guess they don't give this person's
biography I don't know if this man or
woman but the piece is called
black panther brings hope hype and pride
ah yeah and here's what it says it says
I suppose neither of us is used to the
spotlight adapt or to cha wa the Prince
of Wakanda says upon meeting Natasha
Romanova aka the black widow and Captain
America Civil War a few scenes later a
recently orphaned and vengeful - Chava
swapping his bespoke blue suit for a
full-body bulletproof one reappears is a
new Marvel movie superhero the prince
will have to live with the attention
even before it's February 16th released
black panther smashed box-office records
being out Captain America Civil War on
first-date ticket advances and
surpassing Batman vs Superman dawn of
Justice to be gumming fandango's
top-selling superhero movie in history
great ok that's fine I mean sure I mean
I hope the movies good but I do love
this idea that you know this is this is
some sort of amazing moment not since
Spike Lee's Malcolm X has there been so
much hype and mu I'd hoped for a movie
among African American audiences from
the special group outings planned by
excited fans to crowdfunding campaigns
to ensure children can see it black
panther is shaping up to be a phenomenon
in December a viral video of two
african-american men excited to see the
movie's poster with its all-star black
cast this is what white people get to
feel like all the time one man wrote on
Twitter seemed to capture the
anticipation garnering more than 2.5
million views a couple of things about
this one
Black Panther the superhero was crated
by two Jewish guys then just FYI - this
is not what white people feel like all
the time white people don't go around
thinking oh Captain America my favorite
white superhero oh it's amazing
Iron Man white superhero and if you
think like this I would suggest that you
might need to start thinking less
tribally if you spend your life going
around thinking oh my god I'll bet white
people feel just like this every time
they see Tom Cruise in a movie
first of all do black people feel like
that when they go see Denzel Washington
in the movie I doubt it hey black oh man
Denzel now I know I know what it's like
for white people who see Tom Cruise I
have never once gone to a Tom Cruise
movie and thought look at dad that white
guy he's representing and that has never
occurred to me
one time because that's crazy talk and
you shouldn't think like that
okay so then it was created by Stan Lee
and Jack Kirby those were the two Jewish
guys and now Tommy he C codes has
written a new series of comic books by
the way Tommy he coaches comic books out
garbage I've read them they're so bad
the Black Panther comic books so I hope
the movie is much better than the comic
books but here's Deirdre Holloman listen
to this well Conda is a kind of black
utopia there's a country where this
takes place well Conda is a kind of
black utopia in our fight against
colonialism and imperial coll of black
land and black people by white people
said Deirdre Holman a founder of the
annual black comic book festival at the
Schomburg Center for research and black
culture in Harlem so the black
imagination that means everything in a
comic book it is reality and through a
major motion picture it's even more
tangibly and artistically a reality we
can explore for ourselves there's so
much power that's drawn from the notion
there was a community a nation that
resisted colonization and infiltration
and subjugation so a few things about
this one sorry to break it folks Wakanda
is not a real place it does not exist it
is just as real as a scarred yeah it
doesn't not it's not it's not a thing ok
number two this idea that it's a fight
against colonialism and imperial here is
the reason why so many people are going
crazy over this so one of the reasons
people are going crazy over this is that
supposedly they what Conda that the
country of Wakanda in the movie I
haven't seen the movie yet so this is
speculation based on all of the news
reports the the country of Wakanda has
basically been separated from society
for a long time so it's sort of like
17th century Imperial Japan where it's
been separated from the rest of the
world for a long time white people have
not come in there's been no trade with
the outside world except through a
vibranium which I guess is some material
some alien material the landed there and
is extraordinarily valuable and is used
in weaponry like Captain America shield
and they've been able to guard from the
influences of outside culture and
therefore according to the movie Wakanda
is the most technologically advanced
country on planet Earth it is incredibly
advanced it is filled with beautiful
wonderful people who all treat each
other wonderfully it is utopia is just
the greatest place that ever was and
this is being portrayed as reality the
problem that I have with this is that
there is no utopia for white people for
black people or any people it doesn't
exist anywhere there are two countries
in Africa that technically have not been
colonized they're Ethiopia and Liberia
hey there they were Ethiopia was
conquered twice by the Italians but was
never colonized in the formal sense of
colonies being placed there with Italian
who then ruled the roost for a long
period of time Liberia was originally
founded by the United States which
granted sovereignty to the local black
population and the idea was that a lot
of black slaves in America had been
shipped here against their will would be
shipped back to Liberia it was never
really colonized in the in the technical
sense both of those places have severe
problems countries have severe problems
and countries that are isolated have
severe problems - Japan was isolated
from Western civilization for four
centuries that was not great for Japan
it wasn't great for China this policy
North Korea is is completely isolated
from different countries the idea that
trade isolation racial unity that these
are the things you should be aiming for
in a country is a really bizarre idea in
a liberal order in a new order where
free movement of Trade and population
and money is considered a generally good
thing and is better than life all around
the world if you actually found it a
country on the basis that it wouldn't
trade with outsiders
there wouldn't be any cultural exchanges
and that you would actually produce all
you needed in-house it wouldn't be
utopia it would be garbage that'd be a
bad country and just because it's a
country filled with black people that
wouldn't make the country any better you
have cotton that this was sort of the
founding ideology of Hugo Chavez in
Venezuela this is the yoosh ideology in
in North Korea it's not a good idea gee
and there's not a race specific thing
I'm not saying what Conda is bad because
it's black or anything that's stupid I
am saying that if your idea of utopia is
a place where there is no quote/unquote
white influence I'd like to see a place
on the planet where that's a good thing
I'm just at just as I think I'd like to
see a place on the planet where a white
only country has been a good thing with
no cross-cultural pollination right
that's it's silly and the the whole
reason that cultures survive and thrive
is because they adapt in advance thanks
to technological advances they bring in
from the outside and yet this is being
seen as sort of a model and the problem
is that if you're if you're creating a
racial separatist model I haven't seen
the movie yet but if the worship of
Wakanda seems to be this right if if the
worship of Wakanda is that a racial
separatist model is good and that all of
the evils that have been suffered by
folks on the African on the continent of
Africa have been suffered because of
colonialism and imperialism that is
historically inaccurate there are a lot
of reasons the countries in Africa have
suffered tremendously over time they
were suffering tremendously by the way
before
or the before white folks ever got there
there's tremendous tribal antipathy
there's lots of tribal warfare there are
people selling each other into slavery
the the idea of utopia does not exist
anymore
there is no utopia the closest that
we've come to utopia is a place like the
United States where people of any race
any color any background any ethnicity
can live in freedom together while
respecting each other civil rights
that's the closest we've gotten to
utopia and trying to build an
alternative fictional utopia and then
suggesting that we wish that this were a
model for a country on planet earth is
silly and counterproductive okay so
there's my critique of locanda right
then the here here's what it says by the
way the New York Times article wakanda's
rulers have wisely kept their homeland
and its elemental riches hidden from the
world and in its isolation the nation
has grown wildly powerful and
technologically advanced there is no
nation in human history that has become
wildly powerful and technologically
advanced simply through isolation that
is not how things work and it's a
mistake to think this way it's a Malcolm
X point rather than a Martin Luther King
point and I think that that's a problem
okay so we're gonna get to some things I
like and some things I hate now but
first you're gonna have to go over to
Daley wire calm and subscribe so for
$9.99 a month you can get a subscription
to daily wire comm for $9.99 a month and
when you do you get the rest of the show
live to get the rest of the end room
Clavin show live the rest of the
execrable Michael Noel's show live yeah
all of those things plus today well
tomorrow right tomorrow is Valentine's
Day and you can spend your Valentine's
Day in the worst possible way on a date
with Michael moles this Wednesday
February 14th 5 p.m. Eastern the lonely
and desperate Michael moles will
pathetically be waiting for your
questions and your attention in our next
conversation of the Converse our next
episode of the conversation michael's
pathetic hopeless pleas for attention
will stream live on facebook youtube and
the daily wire website it's free for
everybody to watch Roman subscribers can
join the website and ask the questions
to ask questions as a subscriber
laverna daily wire.com head over to the
conversation page and watch the live
stream after that just start typing into
the daily wired chat box and Michael
will answer live questions as they come
in for an entire hour once again
subscribe to get your questions answered
by the just intellectually deficient
Michael Knowles this Valentine's Day on
Wednesday February 14 5:00 p.m. Eastern
2 p.m. Pacific join the conversation and
get all of those great things plus you
got this the famed fabled leftist here's
hot or cold tumblr when you get our
annual subscription for 99 dollars a
year right cheaper than the monthly
subscription or you can check us out
later check out our show later on I too
or SoundCloud please leave us a review
it always helps us overrate iTunes
particularly and at YouTube please
subscribe to our channel we are always
putting up new fantastic content we are
the largest fast explore and
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
all righty time for some things I like
and then some things that I hate so let
us begin with some things that I like so
this was just hilarious okay I didn't
like it because it's a great thing I
like because it's just a funny thing
okay so wls in Chicago was that their TV
station was doing a broadcast about the
Olympics and they accidentally put up a
graphic instead of saying the deuce
taking place in Pyeongchang Richard's in
South Korea they said that it was taking
place at pfj 2018 this is the most
delicious Olympics that you have ever
experienced the PF Changs the only
problem is then apparently you're hungry
for more an hour later so well done WL s
apparently was just a graphic screw-up
some of the guy in the back room it
didn't understand what Pyeongchang was
and so he just grabbed what it sounded
like which was PF Changs 2018 so just
well done WL is pretty spectacular okay
other things that I like so yesterday I
recommended the ego and you give money
to Liberty in North Korea org you should
go over to Liberty in North Korea Oregon
I suggested they help smuggle people out
of North Korea that is not technically
true instead what they do is they help
to ensure the people who have escaped
North Korea are able to make passage to
the West particularly to South Korea
where they get automatic citizenship so
check out Liberty in North Korea org
please give them some money and help
people who have escaped one of the worst
regimes on planet Earth
get to freedom that I think is a
worthwhile thing of course okay other
things let's do let's do some things
that I hate okay so thing number one
that I hate is everybody's going crazy
because Boston Dynamics is a company
that makes machines and they decided
that they were apparently gonna make
machines that are from Black Mirror this
is an exact episode of Black Mirror
where these machine like dogs are
basically murdering humans here's what
it looked like from Boston Dynamics
so that's the last hand you hear before
you die apparently here comes another
one
apparently it's signal to the other
crazy robot dog and the crazy robot dog
has a giant arm attached and it's now
going to open a door because this is one
of the problems that it had it wasn't
able to open the door so now I was able
to open the unlocked door so while you
and your children are hiding in the
closet screaming this is this machine
can open the door and then these robot
dogs can come in killing it so
everybody's going crazy about these
robot dogs oh my God we're all gonna die
from the robot dogs okay I don't think
we're all gonna die from the robot dogs
they have made these dogs capable of
running incredibly fast and jumping and
all this sort of thing I don't think
we're looking at Fahrenheit 451 with the
Hound the reason I don't think that is
because my guess is that you could
probably just hit it and then the
battery would die but one of the things
that this is good for people are asking
why are you making these things for
military purposes of course if you
actually need to open up a place where
for example you think there's an AED
better to send in a machine that can
open the door and get itself blown up
rather than a human and these machines
serve us for the moment but I don't
actually have a particularly negative
view of this sort of machinery honest to
god the only the only type of robot dog
that I really care about is if they
would somehow make a robot dog out of
kosher pork because I really want to try
bacon but other than that I don't care
that much people who are going crazy
over this I think are a little bit a
little bit nuts themselves yeah other
things that I hate so tomorrow is
Valentine's Day
I don't hate Valentine's Day per se
although if you're if you're a spouse or
significant other tells you they don't
want to do anything for Valentine's Day
in the words of Admiral Ackbar it's a
trap so do not do not fall for that one
I will say that this is pretty funny so
yesterday President Obama and Michelle
Obama had their portraits unveiled at
the National Portrait Gallery we talked
about it made fun of it yesterday the
presidents of the United States praised
Michelle's portrait he said it makes her
look hot which is sort of weird cuz she
looks like Kerry Washington in the
picture not Michelle Obama but here is
Barack Obama talking about it um Amy I
want to thank you for so spectacularly
capturing the grace and beauty and
intelligence and charm and hotness
of the woman that I loved okay so number
one just like to point something out um
when a man talks about a woman's hotness
hey even if it's his wife I do it all
the time about my wife but I don't care
about politically correct scruples it is
funny that if let's say Donald Trump
said this about Melania the entire left
with mousse it's freakin gourd right if
he said my wife Melania so unbelievably
hot i mighta boom cover New York Post
other ladies boom right if he had said
that the left would go utterly insane
how dare he be a sexist maintain Melania
can be reduced to her hotness Barack
Obama is allowed to cuz a good family
man other things that I hate so
President Trump continues to maintain
this idiotic completely fat-free
position that aren't for that that free
trade is somehow an enemy to the United
States he said yesterday that our allies
were not allies on trade he doesn't know
anything about trade and it's really
painful to listen to talk listen to him
talk about it the reciprocal tax we are
going to charge countries outside of our
country countries that take advantage of
the United States some of them are
so-called allies but they're not allies
on trade them their product and we won't
charge them anything and we send them or
product same product as they're sending
us and they'll charge us fifty and
seventy five percent tax and that's very
unfair one of the examples got is
harley-davidson they're very they're
treated very unfairly in various
countries you know the countries I'm
talking about so we're going to be doing
very much a reciprocal tax and you'll be
hearing about okay we should not be
having reciprocal taxes on trade okay
the idea of a reciprocal tax on trade is
economically illiterate the idea that if
you go to the grocery store and they
hike the prices on you right therefore
when somebody who works at the grocery
store comes to you you should hike the
prices on them is foolish they will just
go to another place to get their stuff
to get their stuff okay the idea here is
that if you are going to it's so dumb
the idea that if you trade and somebody
puts a tax on the good that is entering
their country making it more expensive
that you should therefore buy from them
at a more expensive price by taxing
yourself is just insipid but this is
because people don't understand trade
and people who critique free trade don't
know anything about how the global
economy actually works here is a great
chart I'm gonna they call neoliberalism
neoliberal a little bit sorry
neoliberalism means freedom of trade
free movement
of labor and cash right this is what
Oxfam which is a leftie organization
cause the era of neoliberalism or so
much suffering has gone on look at this
chart right it shows the percentage of
people living in Pahang or poverty
illiteracy and child mortality look how
it has dropped precipitously from 1990
all the way down to 2015 particularly
take a look at poverty which is dropped
down to below a 30 percent global rate
okay and yet this is what we are
critiquing when we could take free trade
and the free movement of goods and labor
just just silly by the way when I say
for a moment of Labor I don't mean that
everybody should become a citizen of the
United States what I am suggesting is
that if people want to come in and do a
job and work I'm not opposed to that
alright so we'll be back here tomorrow
with all of your latest news updates I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the bench Bureau
show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jesuit Oliveira the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright for
publishing 2018